and that speaker is sui Nevada from
Google and he's going to tell us about
computational Mobility learning
prediction and algorithms
foreign
foreign
I
work at Google leading a small team that
focuses on problems related to
geographical Information Systems
uh being a computer scientist called it
computational Mobility uh
and why because there are a lot of areas
as we find as we'll talk today
that uh fall under this Rich area which
is open to a lot of uh research and uh
future directions
so uh what is it that we are interested
in so uh
to begin with I'm not going to talk
about any specific problem I'll give you
an overview of all the work that we do
here hopefully get uh you interested on
working on similar problems
so what we're looking at at Google is
basically
looking at this entire problem space and
from from the filter of a universal
transportation system right so what do
we mean by that right by that
what we are beginning to understand is
as people move around in the network
uh people are looking for objective
Beyond Simple time and distance right
there are a lot of adaptive adaptive I
mean customizations that people are
really looking for safe routes simple
routes familiar routes Etc
but
to add to this uh
uh complex I mean common complicating
this is basically the inherent Dynamic
nature of this network okay so there are
a lot of closures uh there's traffic the
the network itself changes with new
constructions new points of interest
showing up in the network that people
could be interested in visiting
Etc right
so basically we you can break this up
into three you know three categories one
is first of all what is the network that
we're dealing with
so that's learning the network State you
can probe you can get a lot of signals
from the network speed sensors and the
cities provide Etc
and a combination of these uh we'll talk
a little bit more and as we go forward
and then of course the state itself
since it's Dynamic and it's large
because the network itself is large how
do we represent the stage in a succinct
way
that we could potentially use at one
time okay
so we what we call learning
representations of this network network
embeddings and such uh from the machine
learning world
and then of course finally what do you
do with the state uh you act on the
state by providing some solutions
finding quickly the number of alternate
ways to reach a particular destination
for example
doing multi-objective routing safe but
fast
safe but Scenic and so on and so forth
and of course new routing paradigms are
coming now like the EV routing is
becoming very very important as the EV
adoption uh actually you know takes off
now
so
and yes so and basically
and then we have this new uh what we
call Network optimizations like what we
call social routing maximizing social
welfare and such where we take user
preferences but we don't really I mean
think of fairness is one example right
but what are models of these preferences
that can be included in what we call
Global objectives right in the end we
want the whole network to be stable uh
performance throughput is high and
latencies are small okay
now again given the scale obviously we
have the the system side of things of
doing all this with low latency and
memory
okay so clearly as you can see many of
the ideas that come uh to towards
looking at these problems and modeling
these questions
uh they arise from a lot of areas we are
familiar with to a certain extent like
the classical graph algorithms we have
game theory in terms of incentives and
fairness and cost congestion routing and
so on and so forth of course machine
learning to learn dealing with
uncertainty
classical optimization and then
distributed algorithms to run these
systems efficiently
okay so I'll give you a flavor on the
transportation platform side of things
one of the things that we all know is
the scale of these graphs I mean this
you know
millions of node billions of Ages and
such so we need to be able to deal with
this at runtime in on machines that we
serve any path search query on for
example right and for that we need to be
able to do a lot of pre-processing that
we're allowed and so that at runtime the
queries become fast the state becomes uh
manageable okay so one of the things
that you know uh one of the team members
worked on is partitioning these networks
and then uh we actually had to use some
clever combinations of walks
uh random box and Max flows to produce
some very nice balance separators for
these networks okay
and this is actually being used in the
production system today uh that has
significantly improved the performance
of the system okay and more of course
details of this are available in a blog
post
and uh the architect of the solution is
sitting here in the audience so uh I'll
listen up so you you can talk to him
um
you know later during the course of the
day
similarly another interesting I mean
another important functionality that
these systems should be able to support
are like what I said customizations and
some degree of robustness by that we
mean uh
gave it changes right when things fail I
still need to be able to route you can't
just say there's no route of wealth
available for example right a lot of
customizations and sort of user
preferences and so on and again here Ali
was able to produce some
excellent work on uh using electrical
for decompositions using fast LaPlace in
solvers that has recently come up in in
the in the theoretical literature
and uh we are actually able to now
produce a lot of alternate paths between
any two points extremely efficiently on
these large uh systems right there's
large graphs there's large Networks
uh so that's another very interesting
application of theory and in fact we had
to even make some uh advancements there
to actually actually have this work in
in our systems
and then uh something uh most of you are
also familiar with are these distance
articles can I get a notion of an
approximate distance I mean there is we
don't need to get the exact sort of uh
shortest path but if I can get to get
some approximate distance very quickly
what can I do with it and we are sure
that this is going to enable a lot of
applications for us and then there are
some directions we're exploring in the
space as well
so uh again what is a classic example of
customizable routing let's look at EB
routing that's coming up and now these
are solutions that are coming up in
autos
that uh are embedded in in these in
these vehicles right so there are
vehicles that actually route you through
stations automatically based on the
distance you're traveling time of day
the state of the vehicle and so on and
so forth which makes the problem very
complicated okay
I mean color and uh and his team worked
on this problem a similar problem called
the gas station problem uh in in uh
earlier part of this decade and uh our
last ticket rather and and uh this is an
extension or a similar
flavor of problem
and this is becoming very important as
we launch more and more Vehicles where
we get these embedded Solutions in these
vehicles and uh uh we think there are a
lot of uh
technical challenges that we have to
overcome in these uh to to actually
provide very good Solutions in this
space
I finally when we talked about learning
and predictions uh what do we mean right
so basically these systems inherently
are uh uncertain because of the state of
the network like I said and of course
the user itself the user asks for a
service from this system you don't know
what's the context of the user right
user is in a hurry catching a flight so
there's a low variance route maybe more
important there the user is a local so
familiar route is more important there
or the user is a traveler yeah thank you
and so on so how do we deal with these
different user preferences right so we
found that there is a class of online
learning models that can be very nicely
adapted here
both in Bandit settings and expert
settings
where we have explored different probing
models using auxiliary information to
actually improve the performance of
these learning systems
and and uh we got some very good results
there and hopefully uh this will
translate to some very uh uh interesting
implementations and applications in the
space
and the last big area here is not last
but one of the other big areas is
understanding the network itself right
so like I said we have all these
information now how do we succinctly
deal with this information that's
representing it is one and of course
getting this information itself is the
other so uh can we basically
understand this network better in terms
of how we get the information what we
call the quality of your of our lens
right the quality of lens that you focus
on a particular part of the network to
get information about the state of the
network
right and that itself is a non-trivial
problem and and there are a lot of
problems that come up in the space and
of course learning representations is
the classical embeddings and all the
related work that is there in the space
uh that could be used to basically
represent these networks at the right
granularity so that uh the model change
the model dependencies and correlations
in the network and of course that useful
to answer the queries you want to answer
with very low distortion
so uh so here again we are looking at
different uh architect deep net deep
learning architectures here so you see
how we can
um you know answer these questions
and like I said the one of the important
things is uh
you know this capturing this information
about multiple scales and across time so
there's spatial and temporal changes
and also you would like these embeddings
to make sense so if they are you know
they should have some nice properties
that if they are close together or they
represent in the same space that is
close together then they should be
similar or if there are if there's some
kind of lipstickness if if you will of
you know change in time and space
so we should be able to satisfy these
properties as well right and then
finally uh unlike say the distance
Oracle kind of uh settings
here the other key uh
you know uh requirement is that they
generalize to multiple tasks
right so you would like to be able to
answer shortest path queries you should
be able to answer uh use it for
predictions ml models or predictions in
speed predictions for example event
predictions uh traffic jams and such but
it should be exactly the same uh you
know representation that could be used
for all these applications
so that's another important criteria
here for problems in the space
so yeah so I think this is basically to
just give you a flavor uh of all the
things we do and it covers a lot of
areas that could be a potential interest
to many of you in this room and uh uh we
welcome you to talk to the folks here
and learn more about what we do and
encourage internship and student
researcher applications
thanks
[Applause]
someone have a question
hey uh thank you for the great talk uh I
will my name is I'm a data scientist so
coming from that perspective I have a
question uh about uh so it's always a
statement to say like you know at least
half the world you will go to Google
maps for directions like finding
directions so there's also a large
number of users using that right that in
turn affects the traffic and the flow
Network so other models or algorithms or
approaches that take into account that
feedback uh of like you know users using
and thereby changing the network
properties and they're by changing and
looking at the diapers how does that
work absolutely so we do use that right
so that's the quality of events I'm
talking about you get information about
the network feedback that gives you an
update of what congression there is and
so on but how accurate is that how real
time is that so these are all questions
that come off as Leaders but yes
foreign
so I wanted to tell you about uh